foreign
Jeremy in Louisiana Jeremy welcome to
the show
how are y'all we're doing great man
what's going on
so I always wanted to know uh I'm about
31 725 in total debt not that you're
counting down just about it
so my 2013 Toyota Tundra with a 22.99
interest rate oh my gosh I know I know
which we can pay off in the next four
months uh after we get our tax return
we're getting about 2500 back I've only
got 3 600 left on it what's it worth
it's anywhere between you know 12 and 15
we're thinking
and then once you if you sold that you
would net about 10 grand
well I would probably do a private bill
I'd probably get everything and like you
said actually yeah like you said so
maybe 11 Grand Max and then we have to
turn around and get another car right
no my wife has a car and I also work for
an insurance company so I have a company
truck oh that I can actually drive
around as well so you don't even need to
see the mileage you know
really I don't
um because after we paid off the truck
we would we have about 4 600 on my car
we've got some other credit cards and a
bank loan I mean the most of the debt is
my student loan which is 20 825 what's
your household income
uh per month we make forty four hundred
dollars a month okay so if we sold this
car how how much does it speed up our
debt snowball
uh pretty much it takes out every debt
but my student loan I'm taking that deal
you're freeing up all those payments you
didn't need the truck in the first place
and if you want another truck down the
road we're going to do it we're gonna do
it with cash instead of at 23 interest
good gracious
yeah I know hey Jeremy I know what do
you do for a living
so I was at the time when I bought the
truck as a paramedics I just graduated
paramedic school so I said I need a
truck and I bought that stupid truck uh
but right now I'm I'm a claims adjuster
for an insurance company so you are
smart enough to know blood types how to
stick needles in people how to like
shock them back yeah to life had a CPR
yeah and then you saw that 22 and you're
like this is a great idea that's a deal
it's a great idea it's a great idea did
the salesman have a straight face when
they showed you that it's 23 interest
like what would how do you even deliver
that very good
it's like this is the best thing for
y'all I bet he was like I've seen people
who have higher interest rates than you
man you're getting a deal
did you just have terrible credit yeah
your credit must have been about as good
as old dog poo like how bad was your
credit oh
my credit with the time I think was
about 650 and my my wife had to co-sign
but she had a repossession on her credit
God Almighty Jeremy that's a terrible
rate I'm so glad you're not listen uh
here's what we're gonna do as you're
because you're gonna sell this car by
the end of this weekend is you're going
to be free I'm gonna send you every
dollar app for free for a year and the
new FPU lessons because here's the deal
you all need to watch him again y'all
are kicking butt taking names but y'all
need to watch them again you're one bad
day away from another 23 car loan dude
yes so hang on the line here and
Austin's gonna hook you up with FPU
y'all watch these videos together remind
yourself why you're doing this and for
God Almighty get rid of that truck I'd
walk back into that car dealership and
have some words once that thing's paid
off not even go back in there again just
a thank you letter for teaching me uh
something about life
thank you letter